swapping leather jackets for Christmas
outfits hundreds of motor bikers donned
their Santa costumes for a festive
parade through Berlin and all for a good
cause raising awareness for those in
need in their city just step on the gas
and say take a look especially at
Christmas it is after all the season to
open your heart and perhaps be a bit
more generous cause which I'd like to
support it's wonderful to ride in such a
big group you can see the children in
their cars waving taking photos everyone
is cheerful that's why I want to do it
again every year you ride through the
city everyone laughs when they see us
and waves and they're cheerful and happy
it's great on their tour bikers stop off
at charities bringing gifts for this
care facility for young people they've
brought a couple of TVs ahead of the
parade the bikers collected donations to
be able to fulfill the charities wish
lists when people do something for other
people without expecting anything in
return that deserves a big round of
applause
[Applause]
braving frosty weather the bikers rode
for four hours through the city
Berlin's bikers first came up with the
idea for a parade more than 20 years ago
back then there were just two of them
now more than 200 bikers take part and
hundreds more come to watch
Berlin's bikers have now become
something of a Christmas attraction